we have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two, David p. Here's a very specific
question about retail stores. Why are retail
stores doing so poorly if the economy is supposedly
doing so well?
Hi David. I've got a question for you. You
may or may not know the answer. Um, I'm just
wondering, you see economy's doing so good
as we hear reported in the mainstream media
and a lot of places, they all say unemployment
down, um, employment. Good. The economy's
growing, doing great. Um, why are some many
chains, doors of filing for bankruptcy and
closing down in 2019 Google changed stores
closing 20, 19 and see what comes up. Kinda
really mind boggling that the economy is doing
great. Everyone's doing fine, but there's
bankers fees and stores closing. Yeah. Yeah.
So listen, it's a very good question, which
is retail has been such an important sector
in the American economy for decades. How is
it that the economy you can supposedly be
doing so well if so many retail stores are
closing? And the answer is that the economy
is shifting away from retail. Um, now I don't
want, so let me issued the two very specific
disclaimers. One, you can still debate whether
the economy is or isn't doing well and you
can argue which indicators we should be looking
at. Um, but what cannot be denied is that
the economy in and of itself has been moving
away from retail for a long time and that
there is going to be at a certain point in
time, retail is simply not going to be as
important a, um, uh, a a vertical and industry
to the economy as it once was.
Now, it still is very important. And when
we look at the number of retail stores closing
down due to competition from online marketplaces,
Amazon being one, but there are many, many
others and a lot of these other um, uh, closings,
there is no doubt that this is a negative
force on the economy. The question is, is
it outweighed by job creation elsewhere? And
the question is, well, where exactly are we
talking about? But the move away from retail
has been happening for a long time. You know,
it started, I used to work for circuit city
when I was in high school and college and,
uh, when best buy came and, uh, paid everybody
low hourly wages instead of commission, like
we were paid at circuit city. Uh, it was clear
that it was, it was the, the direction of
retail, no more sort of better trained and
more highly compensated people at circuit
city.
The idea was people making what at the time
I think was eight bucks an hour, uh, to just
clerk out computers and offer service plans
and whatnot. And that was the beginning of
the end for circuit city, which ultimately
folded and a, this is just the way retail
is going so we can evaluate how the economy
is doing. Uh, we can also understand that
retail is just a, uh, not a dying sector,
but a sector that is being reformed and reshaped
and, and far less prominent than it was once
was. We've got a great bonus show. We will
talk about a whole bunch of different stuff,
including 42% of Americans being at risk of
retiring
broke. Get the bonus show, get the, uh, commercial
free audio and video screen by becoming a
member or patron information about both on
our website, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com